vous avez une minute je vous emmène à
Guill en cours où Renault vient de
présenter roods le plus grand simulateur
de conduite immersif de la
planète ce bijou technologique est une
avancée majeure dans l'industrie
automobile il offre la possibilité de
mettre à l'épreuve des véhicules dans un
milieu virtuel mais réaliste imaginez un
écran monumental qui recrée une route en
conditions authentique vous permettant
d'évaluer tout de la tenue de route au
réaction du véhicule dans des climats
extrêmes ce simulateur est un levier
d'efficacité pour Renault résultat à une
réduction du nombre de prototypes et une
fiabilité accrue des productions en
série vous pouvez recréer des
simulations météorologiques variées
comme une chaussée en soleillé ou encore
une route enneigée et adapter en temps
réel le comportement du véhicule si
l'innovation et la technologie
automobile vous fascine gardez un œil
sur ce simulateur made in Renault le
premier véhicule entièrement développé
avec roads est prévu pour une
commercialisation en